yes the question actually had to do with
a very fantastic super tournament that
just took place the strongest tournament
of the year the strongest round-robin so
far of the year just took place in
Zurich it was a six player elite field
that played it kind of a remarkable
trifecta if you will
they had a blitz round-robin and they
had a classical chest round-robin and
they had a rapid chess round-robin and
the organizers used the blitz as a way
of determining the the move number of
the players so that those players those
three players who did better in the
blitz got the three higher numbers for
the classical and from the classical for
each point scored in the classical you
got two points for the overall standings
and the final rapid you got one point
and that was the combined scores blitz
excluded long story short the Swann
Athan Anand won the classical portion he
got caught by America's Hikaru Nakamura
as they both finished the competition
with nine now my understanding was that
in case of a tie in the combined scoring
they would use a tiebreaker a tiebreaker
such as how did you do against each
other and the heads-up match well the
tie breakers all favored Anand he Vichy
had defeated Hikaru in their individual
classical game so if you were going to
use their heads up you got to declare
and on the winner if you use a buckled
system an on had a superior Buchholz and
so on so there was some confusion or
actually there was and I just thought a
non won the tournament
then came the discussion that the
organizers were want to have a playoff
to determine the title and I think such
things are fine they're great
I love playoffs I really do I think that
that that tournament should be decided
over the board in case of a tie I'm all
in favor of that but I really want to
see that before the tournament begins in
other words make your rules everybody
knows what they are beforehand and don't
change a midway my understanding is that
this was actually a change by the
organizers almost post fact you know
like okay now we got a tie it's not nice
to give the trophy to one guy and a
lesser trophy to the other let him
decide it over the board my
understanding it was going to be a
tiebreaker and that a non had won the
tournament so he karo definitely got
lucky in the sense that the tiebreaker
was decided to be played
necessarily clinched I agreed again the
point the observation there is if an
ongoing into last game for argument's
sake was under the impression that a
draw secures the worse a tie for first
he goes for the draw and they said no
you're gonna have a playoff
maybe his strategy would have been
different and I couldn't agree with you
more I think that that is the type of
determination you need to make before
the tournament takes place so for
example we're gonna have a US
Championship man and US Championships
coming up at the end of March start of
April and what happens if two players or
players play for first if you say we're
gonna use a Buchholz bingo got it if you
say no we're gonna play two games of
rapid chess and if there's not a winner
we're gonna play two games of blitz
chess and if there's not a winner we're
gonna play an Armageddon
boom got that right but you don't just
say let's play an armageddon-like I mean
now I'm again it's I only comes after
you've exhausted all the other
tiebreaker things so I was a bit
surprised and especially for a
tournament of what a great caliber
Zurich is yes yes yes yes the question
is if the organiser kind of makes this
last second change or you know yes
you're a good guy your opponent's a good
guy you know the audience is all here
would you please be so kind and blah
blah blah play the game I am really
really cognizant flexible recognized
there's an audience grateful to the
organizers for making such a great I'm
really flexible on such matters
where it's not for the World
Championship Lord's not for the United
States Championship
conversely I'm absolutely totally
inflexible when I'm playing in a World
Championship cycle and the rules have
been set the set in stone there's no
flexibility here we're playing for the
World Championship we're playing for the
United States a coveted if I play on the
chess Olympic team I want those rules I
want to know what happens when two teams
tie are we going to play a blitz or are
we not going to play a blitz we're gonna
use a Buchholz we're going to use a
Sonnenberg Berger tie breaking system
heads to head matchup thing so I'm just
saying that we're really important
national international titles are at
stake no those things are clear in a
private tournament like a Zurich like a
sink fill Cup you know I'm going to have
fun I'm going to be more amenable okay
but I think it's still a bad idea to do
things on the fly I would have I would
have Allah I would have played would
like Anand I would have played but had
it been World Championship Magnus
Carlsen time and they said mmm yes sir
the the you're not gonna play a playoff
in case of a tie it's the player who won
more games with black it's going to
determine the title I happen to win more
games with black I am NOT
yeah I I didn't I don't know I don't the
question as regards what was there some
negotiations and how does the how was
the prize money impacted by the playoff
and such questions I don't know what was
really surprising for me was the format
of the playoffs again I mean if I had
been in a non shoes and I said okay look
we all know I'm the tiebreak winner
right okay why does shoot for an
Armageddon you've got a you've got a big
audience there in the there in the
playing hall there online why don't we
play two 5-minute games two ten minute
games we will just play back and forth
you get black I get black right okay and
then we'll go to the Armageddon I mean
it just seemed very surprising so there
had to be some negotiations along the
line that you're saying and did they did
did the players discuss you know a
10-minute game and then two 10-minute
games and two 5-minute games in 2-3
minutes games or was it just Armageddon
it or boss or only Armageddon or not I
don't know and I'm very curious I mean
waiting for the players to be to
interview to explain what the
negotiations led to